A slice of pizza simply melts in our mouth.
A bite of the delicious burger is
never a “no-no”.
And what about desserts?
A piece of cake or a brownie is
always at the top of our wish list!
Whatever food we eat, it always has to pass
that churning process or the
physical break down!
Mastication, that is chewing, is one of the
most
important commencing steps of digestion.
And who helps in this process?
The
sole components of the buccal cavity involved
in mastication are the TEETH!
They help in biting, chewing and grinding
the food we eat.
Let us have a look at the “Teeth” in detail
in this video.
To understand teeth,
let us begin with knowing the structure of
a typical tooth first.
A tooth consists of two main regions.
One which is above the gum surface and
the other is present below it.
What are gums by the way?
Gums, also called the
“gingiva” are the soft tissue linings
in the mouth.
But gums appear to be so
hard.
So how can they be called soft tissue linings?
Well that is because gums
are soft tissues, but they are tightly bound
to the bones under them.
They act as the anchoring point for our teeth.
They help in firmly holding the
teeth at their position.
In humans for example, the teeth are firmly
rooted in
the sockets formed in the gums.
This morphology gets a name “Thecodont”.
This simply means the type in which teeth
are embedded in the sockets
formed in the gums.
Now after having a glance at the gums, let’s
look at the actual tooth!
This is
what a typical tooth in a vertical section
looks like!
Let us begin from the top!
Here, this part, seen above the gums is called
as the
crown!
So the part which we can see is the crown
of our tooth.
Since the crown is the
part exposed to all types of food particles,
and which encounters microbes as
well, it needs to be well protected!
Hence, it is coated with an extremely hard
covering named ENAMEL.
Now if I ask you, what is stronger, a bone,
or the enamel?
I am sure your
answer will be Bone!
But that is not the case!
It is actually the enamel!
Yes!
Enamel is the hardest tissue or substance
in the human body!
The next layer after enamel is also extremely
hard.
This layer is what we are
talking about!
It is called the Dentine.
What do you think would be its
function?
As we can see here, the dentine mainly acts
as a connecting bridge
between the crown on top and this root lying
below it.
Root?
Do teeth also have roots?
Yes they do!
This region is referred to as the
root of this tooth.
Just like plant roots, these roots help in
anchoring the tooth
firmly in the socket of gums.
Now let us talk about the next part… this
one!
Do you know what this is called
as?
It is called the pulp!
And why so?
Well, the portion is extremely soft and
fleshy, and is richly supplied with blood
vessels and nerves.
So whenever we
feel the pain in our tooth, it is this region
that sends us a signal!
So is that its sole function?
Of course not!
The blood vessels in the pulp help in
nourishing the tooth.
Now, are you able to locate this part?
This is called the Cementum.
Isn’t the
name self-explanatory?
Yes!
It acts like a tough layer that covers the
complete
root.
As you can notice here, the structure widely
spreads across the complete
root of the tooth.
So this is the structure of a typical tooth!
The crown is this top most region that
is usually visible to us.
It consists of an extremely hard protective
layer called
the Enamel.
Below this, is the dentine.
And just below the dentine comes the
root which has this fleshy pulp, richly supplied
with blood vessels and nerves.
This is one more layer named Cementum that
covers the root from below.
And
this root is embedded in this jaw bone as
we can see here.
This bone is covered
on top with the gum.
So this is how the complete tooth appears
to us in a cross
section.
So are we done learning about the teeth?
Of course not!
There are several
amazing concepts yet to be covered.
Let us meet in the next video and cover
these concepts!